has gone Grossman is paid back I was out
chopping wood and I came back and I'm
like I'm gonna play someone till dawn
this is my favorite game to play right
now this game was [ __ ] awesome
there's a clown [ __ ] we're just lucky
he just what a dick move he was proud of
that move he was just like yeah what's
up oh no it's closed now
no no it's locked
oh no I could just collide that yeah no
that's pretty tall there's no way in
hell I can get across that do agree with
uncool [ __ ] but some things you have to
see for yourself
they hinting to me that josh is alive
because I already call that [ __ ] game
alright
I've seen through the plot I know what's
gonna happen brush josh is the killer
he's working with the thing
and that's it because the thing out in
the woods was trying to save this a sir
write a clue so it makes sense it all
adds up brush will break the door down
will ya whoa wait a second we start
smashing [ __ ] down he's gonna hear us
thank you Matt just became my favorite
character butch what window that's great
Matt I can just about fit my blip
problem through that little slot oh come
on you will never fit through there big
guy we're gonna help Amy Emily through
I won't fit but you will are you nuts
you're gonna shove my ass through that
little hole yes you slip into some
pretty tight jeans and yeah I've seen
how tiny your asses probably just
sitting there under that window waiting
to blend this into pina coladas mind
your outline here goes huh what a dick
face I don't want it I don't want it she
deserves to die if she lives and my man
Matty B lives then I'm gonna be pissed
I'm gonna be pissed
I don't shut it's Matty it's that M on
his jacket supposed to be for Matty
cuz that's cool that's cool that's how
you get an Asian girlfriend
he's kind of skinny for a jock isn't he
doesn't really act like one either
that's why I like Matty you don't [ __ ]
with the Matty be it's got to be the guy
the the one who who got to Chris and
action John got it all this is the only
way back don't say that look
I mean that's not far right you can jump
it shut the [ __ ] off how about that so
if you don't move it it goes in on the
character
can I just experiment that it does
that's really cool you can really see
their emotion you wouldn't be able to do
it and what if we get ya fix it
oh there's a radio tower
we should go there Hey look fire tower
hey Magellan maybe we should get the
cable car working and take the show on
the road huh let's just say die die
there are they not gonna talk about that
it's a sty everywhere
very friendly unfollow unfollow ah Beach
let's talk to her no what is that what
is this what is this what is this it's a
great ticket East I can't do anything
then what's the point
great no keys no cable car so just wear
one
I feel like it's fitting that I have the
ax yeah we gotta get to that radio
that's what I was saying that's what I
was saying yeah [ __ ] somebody's got to
pick up the signal yeah no everyone Wow
someone's learning to play by the rules
what what what rules funny rule number
one
Emily is always right [ __ ] rule number
two nothing else matters because emily
is always right [ __ ] I will punch you
in the ovaries what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you my god what is this what am I
looking at
what is this hello hello what is oh
there I am
hello oh my god piss me off
what is she doing over there no [ __ ] you
I'm gonna look at these
she's taking a [ __ ] you better not take
a [ __ ] where I'm gonna go and take a
[ __ ] cuz that's my [ __ ] corner over
there good it's clean problem have a
good idea I hate you you ruined my life
where am I going
oh [ __ ] say man I hope she dies I hope
she dies good I want to play us the
bubble bath girl like how long has she
been in the back did you sure just
friendzone me
we can totally get out of this BAM
save your ass [ __ ] you're right yeah
yeah to protect me okay
almost almost I'm feeling kind of down
okay
I could help holy cannoli
for real yo that was sick bro alright
well that was she actually helped so I
guess we can't complain too much where
are we now I really want to place a
bubble-bath girl I think she could
potentially be favorite character
potential wife that's it that's true
actually I agree with Harris climb down
that's what I was thinking yeah it beats
getting [ __ ] kill see that's what I
was thinking
yeah that's exactly what I was thinking
okay well you know what you guys are
doing some good thinking right now proud
of you
maybe you guys aren't so bad after all
thank God it's so annoying when everyone
just makes the wrong idea
like I don't mind if they make the wrong
look I get the outcome in Oh God it's
not perfect but if they got the wrong
ideas it's just frustrating you know it
seems so simple what you should do in a
scenario like this I understand things
don't have to work out all right this
beard is very sweaty like I don't know
how beer do people do it I just drank
like a bunch of testosterone and this
thing disappeared totem what is it what
is this totem yo that's a deaf totem
isn't it fortunate owner I'm not
confused by the totems I thought like
they would happen kind of like Alan Wake
style where you some you would read in
that game you would read a page and then
what happening that page will come true
like a little later so far I haven't
really
seem too much danger cliff all right you
can take your attitude and shove it up
your pooper all right this is where Hina
and the other girl fell didn't they
Maddie B do something mad at B that's a
snake oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] you know
what you do in a situation like this you
pretend like you're the pack leader or
it ought to push the girl in and run for
your [ __ ] life there's clearly a gap
there to the left
so just take her and like go like a
Pokemon huh she's enjoying yourself
still
oh god that's creepy
I didn't see him how long do you take
baths in girls man guys maybe she lock
the door so she doesn't know anything of
what happened okay I write I write
everything
hey hey hey how's it going what's that
what's that what's that what's that but
has this towel is very very good no no
no I don't want to go out I was clicking
the other thing Chris Gerace Josh Josh
my clothes really cold not cool at all
look at mine f ha just to stop it that's
a pretty and my bracelets matching
alright well I better just go around
with my tower my tower
alright alright I enjoyed this I enjoyed
this a lot this is very nice they
created it at that a balloon
is that a [ __ ] balloon I love
balloons how did they know this said my
birthday already oh this is creepy it's
very very creepy there's nothing here I
want to look for clues and stuff okay
all right and it is kind of weird cuz
these people these like well I mean I I
don't
but like Oh God Jesus Christ stupid
clock I mean guys if you're gonna do a
jump scare you need to build a little
bit more attention I'm just saying
otherwise no one's gonna get scared Mike
Emily this is really getting out of hand
okay it was all very funny haha look at
Sam walking around in a towel oh the
balloons have arrows on them really want
this to be over
all right no they do yeah that towel is
really oh yeah
picture of the sister but you know what
I she wasn't there you know what she was
there when it happened
you're right but but she was the only
one like who was pissed about it that's
two sisters Josh and her ready for the
senior prom yeah I think this girl is
the one that's gonna live
she's the virgin protagonist I doubt
she'd suffered Oh
freak me out guess what you succeeded no
it seems kind of cute they just love
playing pranks on each other so much
are you guys Cowboys guys I'm done with
this I really don't appreciate the
silent treatment here hello Samantha hey
how's it going looking for me are you my
clothes I don't think you'll have much
luck looking so now god damn it where
are you it sounds like the same lisps ad
as Josh generations looking at doesn't
she
thank you a beautiful bathing bird
I do you think she has any idea what
lies ahead do you think these were the
last happy moments of this creatures
life why are you watching I think bison
I'm going to give you 10 seconds 9
throw me take this
whatever the ten seconds
trying to make the right decisions here
trying to stay alert
he's gonna find us
can't make no handle
oh there's the handle are you kidding me
come on this is so intense
oh my god yes
that felt good that felt really [ __ ]
good how is that towel still what oh
[ __ ] what that [ __ ] paola still on whoa
what that [ __ ] we saw this this is one
of the tonin's except we were wearing a
bikini so I think we we lost the bikini
chance which add sounds like good thing
if you ask me I don't know anything
about the bikini 100 maybe they stay I'm
we running we're getting out of here
we got a trophy
what I don't think we did it right III
honestly think she they get caught
either way and really hit their yeah it
was thank you yeah think so oh and you
just gonna use this heart in your
overwhelming fear of isolation you know
turned it against these people who you
should test were the one to torment
how's it been worth
now I'm just confused
that was [ __ ] weird wasn't it I can't
let's look at what we're missing this is
insane we need to go get help
hello guys yes hello Savannah top okay
for me we should look for the others
Mike and Jess are off to sixty-nining
each other and who knows where Sam is
she's in the lodge why are we still
talking about this let's go Hey look
fire tower
what is that I don't know there we go oh
man I hope the Asian lady dies
get ahold of yourself relax
[ __ ] dear it's fine check us out
no no no Matt it's gonna hurt us
I'm not moving
my daddy does
hey how's it going
babban ffffff better kill iation that's
your chance taking it slow
are you the king dear
hello dear king now not going to do that
okay
please pray with your dear king
okay we did it we did the right thing
there good job Russ good job Emily now I
hate her she's such a [ __ ]
crooked I gotta say though I love the
game play and I love the game we go back
to the lodge and get everyone else we
should stay here in case whoever it is
needs to get back in touch with us let's
get that radio working first I think
it's super good this game so far I like
I love it I'm super impressed by it I
think it would be cool if they had it
was a little scarier I feel like it's
all jump scares so far it's just a
security like motion sensor probably
yeah right
well that actually makes sense huh kind
of like them together now they're not
they're not too dumb you know
babbit a bat bat bat bat bat up evident
that peppered FFF father did you okay
we're heading up here see what we can
find inside this is the radio tower that
we were talking about exploring I have
beard in my mouth
let's go up here well our boyfriend
stares at our ass you enjoying the view
honey you enjoying the beer
you like it you like this Asian people
don't have butts no we don't know we
don't what's that a little bed races
pretty sure you can still climb with an
axe buddy pretty sure you can just leave
it don't leave it I wonder if there's
gonna be the plot twists or I wonder if
I'm right
like I'll be seriously like if it's not
Josh bending Oh cuz you're high up bee
bee
where is he
I can't see him
yeah yeah
okay this looks cool what is this after
it left when the two best buds in the
game are already dead so I don't really
like how much to fight for you know I'm
saying
and it would be fun if they play more on
the cliches part as a trope kind of like
going with it as a joke or something but
still make it awesome because I think
cliches can be cool if you as long as
you don't do them on purpose as long as
you do the Mumper I mean sorry and do it
right that's a printer yeah let's go
printer why are we going out let's look
around a little bit more why don't you
bring the axe like give me a good reason
just give me a reason shocker power
gotta be a switch here
I would say that they could camp out in
the radio tower but he could easily just
set it on fire and we'd be dead I don't
know and it's too cold to be outside of
the entire night so I don't really know
I guess he'd find them eventually
unless have a really good hiding cool a
flare gun that's really useful you go no
no no yeah exactly what was that you can
use it as a gun sale
good have them one shot and when I want
a shot didn't it alright we're going in
oh there's a fuse box interest really
that was it
okay today's our lucky day shh-shh
he's gonna burn the thing down or get
the axe or suck a dick all right I don't
like this don't like this you guys
should have waited with the [ __ ] Flag
guys let's find a frequency what do we
got
let's try that again
she wasn't cooking cannot can I talk
yeah let's just [ __ ] listen
the ski lodge
they mustn't Great Tribulation sensor
probably I [ __ ] dare until dawn maybe
you should have brought the ax you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
sorry is that the deer ah man it be I
trusted you
I thought you recall [ __ ] idiot oh
great
this thing is gonna polish like your
mama dance on the dance floor
all right good times good times forehead
sorry Emily you're gonna [ __ ] back
come on I click that that's the problem
Emily no one wants to Jesus don't have
[ __ ]
again
Wow
mad in the minds but mad and demands may
be jealous all right let's keep doing
mad in the minds missing
okay I'm sure we can make it out of here
it's probably not good to be in the
mines oh she's still alive damn it this
[ __ ] for real I saw you with Mike let's
just not that you're gonna be fine
[ __ ] you yelling at me I hate her this
out okay why do you question every
little thing I say I'm goddamn sick of
it
whatever you say you [ __ ] [ __ ]
whatever you say princess I hate her
I'm not gonna kill someone because I
hate them all right that's stupid but if
they happen to die I don't want to tip
it
alright let's try and save her one more
time
that was good I was hoping that would
happen thank you so much game thank you
so much for killing that [ __ ]
no no not Emily not my [ __ ] girlfriend
see now I'm gonna get so much pathetic
everyone likes a widow especially a man
Widow let me comfort you so hand
what is happening
oh [ __ ] what what the [ __ ] just happened
what the [ __ ] man you can't just kill me
without a QuickTime event what was that
what the [ __ ] was that she was what
there [ __ ] on the [ __ ] no I'm sorry I
need a break that's not cool man
that's not cool what the [ __ ] was that
about
Bruce aren't you confused nothing there
was a ghost that [ __ ] Danny
alright now I'm seriously [ __ ]
what if we got another clue huh Miami
I'm proper pissed that matter be Dino
let's just find Sam
look at this Chris that's the vase we
threw no forensics expert looks like it
was goddamn it oh my god there's spirits
and shed
what does shed I am very confused right
right yeah that all right my theory is
if spading man what is going on here
wait a minute did you just see that why
did I see why that quit what that was
that I didn't see it I'm serious
did you see it why don't you believe me
I said I saw it doesn't that count for
anything hell tonight okay your mind is
fried my mind is fried I don't even
trust what I've been seeing
let's just concede I don't know I don't
know I just I saw something Chris ash
it's okay you just we're we're both kind
of out of our heads right now I mean we
just gotta pull together there's no
point in panicking anyway so I think it
doesn't matter if we saw it it's the
only place left Sam could be ash I wish
we could just go find everyone else and
what if Sam needs us what if she's in
trouble
Oh God are this maybe the spirits of the
sisters are helping us that would make
sense
these people were any mold I'm so
confused
I'm trying to think trying to deer rice
I'm not sure they actually look like
Shanique she could use a cat right now
cute little kitten
this is very creepy I don't know the
jump scares are not doing it for me
anymore like a they had so many in the
beginning so I thought alright well
that's cool they're just keeping us on
our toes
scared spirits and you're covered in
blood I'm not imagining things that's
what I'm worried about
oh I know no you know what I'm really
worried about ok I'm worried about Sam
what's happened to her there's some
maniac out here please Kris maybe she
wants us to save Sam cuz Sam was the
only one defending oh that's the
scenario that's what happened the night
so it makes sense what I was saying
guess you need a key if you want to play
around a
around in there am i right ladies
up top break it down that do me now now
girl now maybe there's something in here
this is where she went
why is the bookshelf not down oh he put
it back up again another clue they
should be locked there's no handle
I can't handle when there's no handle
can't handle when there's no handle
[ __ ] why although like I said the fact
that there is no the jump scares aren't
doing it for me anymore I am enjoying
the gameplay alive what seriously Chris
get some reaction time oh my god the
ghost of what your freaked out because
of what happened with Josh paying
attention I saw it I saw a ghost
and it look like what do you think they
followed us up here from the singer I
don't know they did it because ghosts
don't exist okay okay I was talking to
us at the seance press I don't know Josh
oh [ __ ] what the I be freaked out if
that happened picture just jump up the
wall like that that's a good question I
want to see your face it doesn't zoom in
good booty going want to smooth @potus
moving order smooth who wears pants like
[ __ ] these when they go into the
[ __ ] Alps like jesus [ __ ] christ
alright maybe we're going to oh my god
the [ __ ] was that 360 showing us the way
it's a good girl okay
well we already know what we're gonna
see in the dollhouse it already kind of
showed us for some reason I feel like
the ghost wanted me to see this
are they all naked what's going on oh
god it's like it's not like anything
that's us ha ha ha waiting for Han last
year
but it's it's so accurate I mean that's
exactly where I was sitting and that's
where Matt was was set up by someone who
was there or someone or something that
was watching I maybe it's a warning
I think someone I think someone put this
here to mess with him no it has to be
the ghost is trying to tell us the
maniac killed Hannah bad I think it's
this bastard that he's easier trying to
[ __ ] with our heads why would he set
this all up Chris he's trying to tell us
that he's gonna come after us all -
yikes
indeed ok 2013 it's Hannah's diary oh
this will be juicy mom finally agreed
the invitations are out the party's
gonna happen I hate that I have to wait
so far ash Matt and Sam have said
definitely yes nothing from my sad face
Oh oh my God my confirmed he phoned
Joshua this afternoon Oh
woohoo party time they're here on the
mountain it's gonna be so awesome
cozy fires and hot tubs and oMG Mike I
am so psyched to spend some time with
him I can't read this
gross I hate to do this to you but I
have to end this episode here okay don't
worry we'll be back tomorrow don't worry
it's gonna be okay alright thank you so
much for watching and I'll see you in
the next one please it'll like be
enjoyed and